TOM HIDDLESTON
My new series, Loki, is coming soon
to Disney+. And to help
get you ready, I'm going to catch you up
in just 30 seconds.
My dad, Odin, says
my brother, Thor, can be king.
I'm jealous, plus he's not my real Dad,
so I get my real dad to kill Odin,
but then I save him.
Thor's mad anyway, and we fight.
Cut to Earth:
I steal the Tesseract from S.H.I.E.L.D.,
help the Chitauri invade Earth,
the Avengers stop them, and I go to jail
until Thor needs me to help defeat
the Dark Elves. Next thing you know,
I'm king, but everyone thinks I'm Odin.
Our sister Hela shows up, cue another
Thor and Loki team-up, we beat her,
then Thanos shows up, we don't beat him,
and I die.
Thanos kills half the universe,
the Avengers go back in time to stop him,
giving an earlier version of me
a chance to grab the Tesseract...
Oh, hang on!
Okay, that's better.
Thanos gets defeated,
and next thing you know,
I've got a job offer from some group
that calls itself the TVA. And that's it!
Find out what happens next
by streaming Loki, exclusively on Disney+.